Andrew it's been uh well nearly a
year since we last sat down together
very different time it was in my London
studio and eight days after that you got
arrested what's the year been like for
you it's certainly been an interesting
one I've been constrained this entire
year I spent 93 days in a Romanian
dungeon five months locked in my house
and now I'm restrained within the
country of Romania so it's certainly
been a
turbulent time the moment you got
arrested it was all pretty dramatic the
video came out the world saw it a lot of
people smashing into your your home did
you have any inkling warning that
something like this may happen I knew it
I kept saying before I was arrested on
every single podcast I did I said you
get three lives in the world the first
life they're going to cancel you they're
going to slander you they're going to
delete your access to social media so
you can't defend yourself the second
life they're going to try and put you in
jail for no reason and if you continue
to speak against the power they're going
to assassinate you I knew I was on my
second life I kept saying it I knew it
was coming I didn't know the
reason they'd use but I found out once I
was in a
cell when you were arrested you you
didn't actually you don't speak any
Romanian at all Z and they didn't speak
English to you correct so you were taken
to a cell you had no idea what they were
alleging you done I was arrested on the
27th of December so because of Christmas
and New Year's and other problems they
couldn't even translate my paperwork for
two weeks so for the first two weeks I
was in a prison I had no idea why I was
given papers in Romanian I could read
human trafficking I understood but I was
like human trafficking who when what
none of this makes sense I waited two
entire weeks inside of my cell before I
was given an English translation and
then I realized exactly how ridiculous
the whole case was just to clarify I
accused of helping my friends get big on
Tik Tok that is what I'm accused of I
told some girls I know how to post on
Tik Tok to become viral when I was at
the time the most viral person on the
planet and they are saying I'm a human
trafficker for that that reason it is
insane well we'll come to what you've
been accused of it's more serious than
the way you've categorized it but we'll
come to that there is a lot of
speculation that the reason the Romanian
authorities knew that you were back
because you were on Route I believe to
Dubai for a New Year's Eve party is that
you were interacting with Greta thumberg
on social media and you had a pizza in
front of you which came from a
well-known Romanian Pizza uh store is
there any truth to that I don't think so
I think that they know where I was a lot
of people knew where I was and uh they
had instructions from higher up to teach
me a lesson I was on my second life and
that's exactly what I'm going through
right now there's an irony to your
situation because you always said the
reason you came to Romania was precisely
because you thought you could avoid
being in this situation well I loved
Romania and it's a strong Christian
Nation with strong Traditional Values I
want a life where I'm left alone by
government I don't believe in big
government I'm trying to avoid that if
felt like Romania was a place which was
very safe societally and the government
was not too interested or involved in
people's lives but things changed also
your freedom and your ability to speak
the truth is heavily correlated to your
insignificance when you become large and
people start listening to what you say
you soon realize you no longer have
freedom of speech and it doesn't matter
where you are are on the planet if they
decide you must be assassinated you will
be
assassinated you in
jail what was that like Romanian jail is
not English jail describe it what was
the cell like I have to be careful what
I say because I don't want to insult the
Romanian justice system which I'm still
beholden to however it's exactly as bad
as people would expect it to be luckily
it was in the winter so the Cockroaches
were not too
bad it was also during Ramadan so I
didn't have to eat so much which was
helpful because of the situation I think
the most stressful thing about it is I
had no idea how long I was going to be
in there for I was dragged from my house
I was given papers in Romanian I didn't
know why I was there I found out why I
was there and it was garbage I couldn't
couldn't seem to get out I could have
been held for years it's very stressful
and uh the best thing you can do is turn
to God and and train as hard as possible
I did thousands of push-ups a day
everying were you in solitary this in
this period three months I no I wasn't
in solitary the entire month the entire
time sometime I was by myself sometimes
I was with other guys and sometimes I
was with my brother so when you were on
your
own were they keeping you in there for
24 hours a day were you allowed out no I
wasn't allowed out there was no yard
time it was 24 hours a day locked in a
single room probably three or four steps
large and you do nothing but stare at
the wall and you think how many days did
you do that for on your own 11 12 I mean
that's a
pretty Grim scenario for for anyone
life's Grim for you always being Mr
confident you've said interestingly that
you wouldn't categorize what you were
feeling as depression because you don't
believe in the concept of depression you
and I have argued about that before but
it sounds to me from what I've seen you
say when you've talked about this that
that was pretty close to depression what
you were feeling life's grim and if you
want to be a superhero you have to
understand in every single superhero
movie he is losing for 80% of the movie
he's going to suffer for the majority of
the movie before he wins at the end I've
always want an exceptional life Pierce
and I'm not a coward and I knew that by
telling the truth about certain issues I
was going to pay the price for it so I
won't say that I deserve to be in jail
but I certainly put myself in there by
telling the truth to the populist and
telling the truth and living but when
you're on your own in that cell what
were you
thinking it's a long time to
self-reflect right it certainly is and I
think my number one concern when I was
in jail despite the fact that my
situation was Dire were my concerns as a
man and all the people I have to take
care of and my children and my family
and the people I pay for and all the
people who work for me and truthfully I
wasn't worried about myself I was
worried about everybody else and I think
that's the true masculine FL frame did
you get emotional did you shed tears in
yourself I'm an emotional man I think I
think men are hyper emotional we just
have to control it I was extremely busy
inside of my jail cell I had lots of
push-ups to do I was very concerned
about the people on the outside I was
trying my best to get
out it's difficult for me to answer the
question because it was a interesting
frame of mind I knew that God was
watching and I had to perform it's very
difficult for me to go through life
saying I'm the top G I'm this I'm that
and speak about mental resilience and
mental toughness and then the second I'm
thrown inside of a solitary confinement
cell cower out I'm not that person
there's some other people who talk about
mental toughness and want to give advice
and when bad things happen to them they
end up addicted to prescription drugs
I'm not a coward and I'm not a liar no
but but it would be perfectly natural to
be emotional in that scenario and
there's no shame in admitting that I was
emotional I missed people I missed them
and I knew they missed me so I felt a
long I felt strong sense of missing but
you
cried there were tears that ran down my
face but I did not cry I mean that's
crying I would disagree because you
you're worried about admitting that you
think it sounds absolutely not that's a
perfectly fine scenario to cry in but I
think the act of crying is an act of
desperation to sit and to cry is an act
in and of itself to do push-ups thinking
of your children with tears running down
your face but you're concerned with
finishing as many push-ups as possible
within that day I do not consider that
crying I consider that tears running
down my face when you found out what
they were alleging you done sexual
assault exploitation and so on what did
you feel about that what was your first
reaction my first reaction was ah the
standard Playbook the standard playbook
for anybody who speaks up against Power
is sexual exploitation isn't that the
normal one they go to can't we name like
10 or 15 people right now they hit him
with this exact same garbage name a full
grown man who's 36 or 37 years old who's
not had sexual relations with a woman at
some point in past and the way the
Matrix works is they lie by Omission
right they just hit Russell Brand with
it I think they hit p didy with it this
morning Julian Assange just got hit with
it he's still in a Cell but lots of
people get hit with these allegations
and it turns out to be true a lot of
people get hit with them and they turn
out to be false so but you're to trying
to make out all the people you just
named innocent you don't know that of
course I don't know that but a lot of
people get hit and it turns why would
you why would you assume they're
innocent well I'll tell you why because
the way the Matrix operates is it choose
something which is heinous if they
accuse me of drug dealing nobody would
care they choose something which is
heinous so the process itself is a
punishment so they damage your
reputation throughout the process
regardless of whether they're successful
or not then what they do is they lie by
Omission they throw you in a cell they
contact everyone you've ever interacted
with 2,000 people I know were called and
they were looking for one person to say
they're a victim by the way they fail
they did not even find one but if they
did they would then say Andrew Tate's
victim he's a sexual assaulter and they
would remove the testimony of the 1,999
people who said I'm a very nice man Lie
by omission and then they put together
this entire package used the mainstream
media to convince the world that you
deserve to be in jail and that is how
the Matrix operates I mean to be clear I
don't know if you're guilty or not I do
sure you're po entitled to say that and
you know right of course I know but I
don't know and I will await any trial
that comes uh to see what comes out in
the trial and see what happens right so
I'm not going to prejudge the trial I'm
not going to judge you and say I think
you're guilty I don't know right we are
where we are you've been charged with
serious crimes and it's likely you'll
face a trial and we'll see how that all
plays out obviously going back to jail
how are you treated by other people
everybody in jail was extremely
apologetic to me all of the staff the
police officers everyone who worked in
the jail the person who serving me my
meal everybody was very sorry for what
happened to me they made it very clear
they knew it was garbage and they were
apologetic that was the only Vibe I
could give you they were kind of like
listen you got too big I'm sorry this is
how things work and sorry here's your
meal nobody had any real problem with me
none of the prisoners had a problem with
me did you get into any finds there was
a a a couple scenarios where violence
could have occurred but I think once
people realized that violence vience is
a certainty and that you do not operate
under a fearful realm they often aren't
so interested so people threatened you I
wouldn't say they threatened me but they
would have liked to have got the
opportunity to threaten me and what
happened and they realized that would
have been a bad decision and all in all
did you what did you say to them because
you don't speak Romanian so I didn't
you're right I actually used a quote
from Street Fighter I said
uh I quoted dson and I said they do not
understand the secrets of yoga fire cuz
I knew they had no idea what I was
talking about it was near the washing
machines and they looked at me like I
was completely crazy and they walked
away there's more than one person
correct and they made they made it clear
what that they wanted to I have to be
careful what I say because I'm still
beholden to the Romanian Judicial System
yeah but that's that's just an incident
in jail that's do with a system corre
incident an incident report was written
and it's better I don't mention it but
there was a direct threat to I've had
threats yeah and I have threats every
single day of my life and I think jail
is a hyper pressurized version of real
realityy and you need to have an
extremely strong mind so you don't
attack yourself and an extremely strong
body so others don't attack you and I
understood that there was a threat of
violence at all times and I just decided
to go through life extremely
respectfully but make it clear if that's
a decision somebody else wants to make
that I'm prepared to partake one of the
things I would think about other than my
family immediate family but one
particular member of my family if I
found myself in jail would be my mother
and what she would be feeling and what
she'd be thinking she's been incredibly
supportive to me I know yours has to you
did you think about your mother I was
extremely concerned for her I was
concerned because the media
establishment were hounding her she was
obviously very worried but she knew she
raised strong Sons but we're her number
one protectors and I was concerned for
her I I wasn't concerned for myself in
jail I didn't even suffer in jail as Mo
as much as I did when I got out I didn't
have nightmares in jail I had nightmares
once I left jail I was in the middle of
a battle I don't think you get PTSD
while you're fighting you get it
afterwards I was in the middle of a
battle trying to make sure sure that
everybody I love and care about is taken
care of and trying to make sure that
bills are paid please understand the day
I was arrested which is a year ago every
single bank account that I have was
Frozen all of my assets were taken I
haven't had a a dollar of money 10 cars
taken I think 15 15 cars and some and
how many properties 15 cars six
properties 20 diamond watches gold bars
Cash Land every single bank account
millions and millions and millions was
the total value of everything They
seized 16 17 million pound
yeah and they took all of it and I still
don't have access to any of these things
I mean as we're doing this interview
you're expecting to hear sometime today
as to whether you may get those
possessions back is it is it all or
nothing do you get it all back or
nothing correct as we sit here the
judges deciding whether I get all of my
items returned or I get none of them
returned and truthfully under the law I
should have never had them taken in the
first place so we're going to see what
the judge decides and I have to put my
faith within the Romanian judicial
system I have no other a choice I'm not
a coward I'm not going to run but let's
not talk about the Romanian Judicial
System let's talk about the Judicial
Systems of the world I've recently seen
some very scary decisions in America in
England in these Western democratic
nations you see people doing 20 years
for attending peaceful protests so you
start to sit and wonder when you're in
these situations what is a trial what is
a judge what is this these are just
people in a room which peace which
peaceful process you talking about
there's been a few and I who who's got
20 years for attending a peaceful
protest I I don't want to say names I
saw it somewhere on Twitter somebody
attended I think it was uh a protest a
prot trump protest and they ended up
getting 20 years well if you're talking
about the January 6th riots they were
riots where people died well this
they're not peaceful protest well it's
interesting because the world is
actually very nuanced and what I tried
that wasn't Nuance that was a a huge mob
of people I to attacking the US Campa
well what I try to do is I try to look
at a a broad spectrum of of events and I
try to put things into a nuanced View
and I don't try and take a instant black
or white point of view on things and the
fact that BLM were rioting and
destroying the entire nation for months
and during that exact week and then some
other people got together with a
opposing political view and are facing
serious prison time for doing less
damage than BLM did I find that kind of
scary because people did die well in a
democratic Nation we should all be the
same under the law B you just to be
clear on January the 6th people died
people died during BLM I mean there are
certainly inconsistencies in the way
groups of people have been policed I
think that's the same that's the same
whether you're talking about the BLM
marches to the pro Palestinian marches
and so on right there's a lot of
inconsistency age in well there's a lot
of inconsistency in global policing I
think I think that's a perfectly valid
thing to say but the idea that someone's
got 20 years for being in a peaceful
March is not true the ones who've got
the lengthy prison sentences have been
held account for serious crime I'm not
even condoning January 6th I don't even
know the ins and outs of January 6th I
wasn't there I'm not saying it should
have happened what I'm saying is exactly
what you have said there seems to be
some massive inconsistencies in global
policing now so when you end up in a
position where you're speaking against
the system as I do and you understand
that there are massive inconsistencies
in policing globally you start to sit
down and seriously wonder if you stand a
fair chance of a fair trial in any
country on earth I actually have to give
a massive credit to the Romanian
judicial system because a judge one day
sat down and said why are these boys in
jail and let us go I don't know if I
would have had a fair shot like that in
many other nations when you were
released from after about 3 months what
was that feeling like I my my brother
and I were in the same cell at that time
we were extremely happy I remember using
the last of my mouthwash during the day
I had some rituals to keep me sane and
I'd enjoy one Swig of mouthwash a day
it's amazing how bored you get when
you're staring at cockroaches and even
that sensation there literally
cockroaches in yourself correct how many
at any given time at night there was a
lot of them like what dozens or yeah a
few there was an infestation we did our
best to kill as many as we could it kept
us entertained but uh they're annoying
to sleep with
but mouthwash was something I enjoyed
every day the sensation of mouthwash
made me happy and I remember using all
of my mouthwash and then instantly my
brain started turning to all of the
things I need to do I'm a man I have
responsibilities for 93 days I wasn't
working I started concerning myself with
okay I'm about to get out of jail thank
God I'm going to leave who do I need to
take care of what's paid do I have any
money left are bills due is Mom okay are
my children okay and I just started
thinking about work and as soon as I got
out I didn't sleep for three days I how
many children do you have I'm less
confidential why because the I have
enemies and unfortunately I do not want
to give them any information but you
have more than one I have more than one
correct right
so obviously you're caring for your
children I understand that as a father
right and obviously and you have a
partner yes are you married no I think I
asked you last time and you were a bit
cryptic about it you're not married yet
no you have a partner who's the mother
of your children correct the same woman
is mother of all your kids it's
confidential it's a bit stupid to say
confidential it it is confidential
Pierce it's confidential I don't think
you marry and have kids with is
confidential sure it is for me really of
course I am a basically number one Enemy
of the State peers look what they've
done to me what have they put me in jail
for at the beginning of this garbage
people were sitting there thinking maybe
he's a human trafficker it's been a year
who show me a picture show me a video
who's even an victim there's nobody the
whole thing is made up well we're going
we're going to come to what they say
you've done right going to come to that
but I'm just curious
you come out of prison you've got no
ability to access any of your assets how
have you been functioning financially
since then I believe in prayer and I
trust in God prayer doesn't pay the
bills and I do my very best but prayer
doesn't pay the bills unfortunately
absolutely everything I own was seized
by the Romanian state so I'm just going
to have to survive and do my very best
but how I'm doing my very best Pier have
you got wealthy benefactors helping you
I'm doing my very best I wish I had
wealthy benefactors I wish I had people
on my side you can't function on on no
income at all seems you can how I'm
doing my very best Pierce what does that
mean it means I'm doing my very best
absolutely everything I own is owned is
taken by the Romanian State I don't have
anything they don't have how do you pay
for food just have to do my
best what does that what does that mean
it means that I believe in God and I
pray going to pay your bills God has
been paying my bills so far it seems
It's amazing how far faith can take you
it's often when you have absolutely
nothing left people turn to Faith but
you should turn to Faith first and you
should believe in God when things are
good and he will be there when times are
initially you were put on this sort of
rolling 30-day house arrest and they
kept renewing that month by month by
month and then in June uh you and your
brother and two others were formerly
charged with rape trafficking and
forming an organized crime group to
sexually exploit women and there were
seven alleged victims named in the
indictment you said at the time I look
forward to being found innocent um you
said earlier who are these women were
there are seven named in the end diment
yeah have you seen the videos of them on
the Internet saying we're not victims
they made us be victims we told them
presumably be analyzed in a trial do you
know when the trial may be I have no
idea it's going to be you believe it
will happen I'm not sure it could get to
a point where a judge anytime before the
trial decides this case is garbage and
throws it away if you ask me what I
believe happened it's very simple they
threw me in a jail cell knowing they had
no case knowing they had no victims but
they thought they plaster me all over
the MSM and they say that I'm a bad
person and they call enough people they
will find the case they want they
couldn't find it you name the date
charged me they had six months to charge
me usually the Romanian State even the
American Embassy confirms to me charges
within 30 days with me they used all six
months trying to build a case and find
actual victims of an actual crime they
couldn't they charged me on the very
last possible day they could unless
they'd have to drop the entire case and
they charge me with garbage because they
have nothing there are no victims I've
done nothing wrong and they've tried
very hard and let me say something very
pertinent to the to the audience here
it's very difficult when you're thrown
inside of a jail cell you do not have
access to social media you do not have
access to money the the entire MSM
establishment are calling you a bad
person hotlines are set up saying if
Andre Tate's ever heard hurt you call
this hotline you're a rich person where
people may want to get money from you
and exploit you and extract resource
from you and they're sitting here
calling anyone you've ever known they
called my Gardener's daughter who I've
never even spoken to asking if I've ever
done anything wrong to her or said
anything wrong to her trying to find
victims of a crime that don't exist it's
actually a miracle from God that no
one's come out trying to extract money
from me whole thing is garbage they
could do this to anybody peers they
could do this to you they could put put
you in a Cell put all over the media
you're a sexual exploiter and for 3
months talk about how bad you are when
you can't defend yourself and call
everyone you've ever interacted with and
if anybody you were ever rude to Once
decides they want a Payday or some Fame
they can use it against you it's insane
the the ranian authorities prosecution
files uh accuse you of using verbal and
physical abuse to keep women in line
taking uh 50% I believe the women's
online income although I believe that
figure could vary could be up to 80% is
that right no the they accuse me of
exploiting women who made who did Tick
Tock the same women who say we were not
exploited he just told us how to do Tik
Tok also in the in prosecution file if
you want to talk about it there's not a
single bank transfer there's not a
single piece of evidence for any money
so I'm accused of making money from Tik
Tok but they haven't found any money
there's no money and the victims are
saying I didn't exploit them to do Tik
Tok the whole thing is a joke what is I
think problematic for you
is the War Room which
was a group miscategorized and
misunderstood called the War Room
correct okay and it had a lot of people
who were dubb the generals who ran the
War Room cor for you and the War Room
had five to 600 members you paid I think
$6,000 plus dollars to be a member of
this and when you saw the the logs of
the web chats between people from the
war room to each other a lot of it made
disturbing reading were you disturbed by
it when you read that firstly a lot of
that is a lot of that's fake
secondly you think they're literally
those logs are fake absolutely secondly
but the BBC verified them the BBC
verified them are they the same people
who verified the vaccine those people
they're Liars firstly a lot of them are
fake secondly the war were you disturbed
by anything you read no because none of
it's real firstly secondly there's 4,000
members in the War Room thirdly the war
room is about masculine personal
development we talk about Fitness making
money strength we talk about very
important things I there's 4,000 members
inside if you're telling me that amongst
4,000 members with 24-hour chat seven
days a week for the Last 5 Years theyve
managed to find two guys talking locker
room talk and that somehow offends the
world that nobody understands how the
world works that's not why I was in jail
it's nothing to do with the war room I
was in jail because I spoke against
Power because I told the truth about
covid because I told the truth about the
war in Ukraine because I told the truth
about all of these things I don't
understand why people would want to put
you in jail with for giving your
opinions about covid or Ukraine why
would they why wouldn't they why would
they why would they say why would they
say that Andrew Tate's opinion is so
important on Ukraine that we have to put
him in jail I don't I don't buy that
okay because I was the most Googled man
on the planet and I had a huge Affinity
with the most Troublesome demographic
for the Matrix which is the young
masculine youth the people who you need
to die in Wars to people who you need to
S off into being slaves to build the
roads while telling them that they're
not allowed a point of view and they're
not allowed an opinion on anything and I
was saying things which was going
against the narrative and the Matrix the
way I oper is it uses the MSM to purport
lies to inject slave programming into
people's brains so that we live lives
which are not good for us but are good
for them and I was sitting there
unplugging it why would they sit there
and say we've put together this massive
sigh off we're going to convince
everybody to inject themselves with
poison and we're going to look everyone
in their houses and it's all a lie and
we're going to let this one gue everyone
listens Andrew Andrew it wasn't all a
lie yes it was it wasn't there was a new
there was a new novel Corona virus okay
I'll tell you what I'll tell you I'll
tell you what I'll tell you what the
facts were and you can then laugh at
them if you wish but there was a novel
Corona virus covid-19 it was killing
thousands of people a day really yes
absolutely yeah and as and I know people
who died who doesn't I know people who
died before Corona of f I'm sure people
died lots of things but it was killing
exponentially thousands and thousands of
people and then vaccines were developed
at very high speed and they managed to
save in my estimation millions of Lies
you may not agree with that but those
are facts as assumed by the body of
scientific and medical experts in the
world the body of scientific and medical
experts you mean the Matrix I could get
what is the Matrix The Matrix are a
bunch of people who can come up with
studies from the sky to say anything
they want them to say so they can use
the MSM to report garbage inside of
people's minds so you end up locked in
your house clapping for the NHS like a
performing seal injecting yourself with
experimental poison for the ninth time
it's a lie there was no reason to lock
everyone in their house more people died
from missed cancer appointments than
anyone ever died of covid people always
got the sniffles before Co they ' always
got it since let me ask you a question
where has Co gone diseases don't go away
where's Co gone it wasn't well the co
strains have got milder as indeed flu
did flu used to kill gone away well flu
pandemic in about a 100 years ago killed
50 to 100 million people and it's got
steadily milder over the decade since
this is normal medical science uh
pathway for most pandemics right so on
that I mean your sort of car IR it was
all Matrix MSM nonsense is palpably
untrue well I'll tell you why that's not
untrue let me tell you my personal
experience with Co I'm an extremely
logical person at the beginning when
everyone was dying dropping dead in the
streets in China which I never saw by
the way funny and the Italian hospitals
were full English hospitals Were Never
full funny me and my brother sat there
and said if this disease is so deadly
and can damage us as strong military age
males and the world is over so there's
no point in hiding in our house we
decided to go to Sweden on day one of Co
day one when everyone still believed we
went to Sweden why does no one talk
about the fact that Sweden was open the
entire time time why does no one talk
about the fact they didn't have masks or
lockdown or vaccines my brother and I
partied in nightclubs s days a week for
three entire months while everyone in
England walk had Sweden actually had a
number of restrictions not when I was
there open not as Draconian as we had in
the UK and there were certainly
legitimate questions to ask about the
scale of our lockdowns I think people
panicked they saw what was happening in
in Italy which had the second best
Medical Health Care system in the world
and people were dying in massive numbers
and the hospitals were overrun so people
panicked did you hear about the guy who
died in a motorcycle crash and it was a
covid death did you hear about that one
well there was certain Downing Street
didn't seem very concerned with there
was a long debate about people dying of
covid or with covid I know all that but
the bottom line for me it is
indisputable that covid was a deadly
pandemic that killed a lot of people it
turned out a lot of older people more
than young people but they didn't know
that at the time not for a long period
the vaccine saved millions of people's
lives there are legitimate questions
about some of the boosters about some of
the side effects of the vaccines as
there are by the way with all vaccines
but the idea that Co is some invention
by The Matrix to suppress and control
its people is for the birds Andrew it's
for the birds it seems the birds and I
friend don't think a smart guy like you
actually believes that of that's one of
my problem one of my problems I have
with you is that I think you are
intelligent but I think you also adopt
positions that you know are going to get
the ant you know the anti-matrix mob
inflamed and it's just these
all-encompassing views you have covid
was a load of nonsense vaccines are all
dangerous and killing more people than
they say said that I said the covid
vaccine well covid vaccine well you
don't think they worked no of course not
because the idea of the the the word
vaccine in and of itself is that you get
they save millions of lives if you get a
vaccine you do not get the disease they
changed the definition of vaccine in the
dictionary so they can continue to
inject us with this pointless poison I
had the vaccine for polio I've never had
Polio you got the vaccine for covid and
you're bragging online how you have Co
for the eighth time but it's not that
bad because you've had six injections
it's insane and please understand my
position please understand that I'm a
person who doesn't believe any of these
studies don't believe any of this
garbage Don't Believe The Matrix I'm a
person who was in Sweden for three
months as everyone was afraid locked in
their houses partying at will and it was
perfectly fine they had a lower death
rate than the UK they had a much higher
death rate than their neighboring
countries in Scandinavia did you know
that they had a lower death rate the UK
did you know that it doesn't no I didn't
know that doesn't matter to you of
course not so you wouldn't compare them
to their immediate neighbors you'd only
compare them to a country in the UK If
you think lockdowns worked Pierce if you
think lockdowns I think lockdowns were
only acceptable as an immediate uh Panic
move which it was before there were
vaccines the moment they had a
successful vaccine program that worked
then there was no justification for
further lockdown you're a very important
person and you're very well respected
I'm not important I'm a journalist no
you're very important and you're very
well respected within the UK and you've
been famous for a very long time were
you invited to the party at Downing
Street or were you not in that S no no
that's a shame and I thought the behav
they seemed very concerned about Co on
the TV and they didn't seem to give a
soon the TV was on I thought that
was disgraceful and I thought Boris
Johnson and the people working at number
10 who were having those parties uh when
I had friends of mine who were literally
saying goodbye to their mothers on
FaceTime on their phone because they
weren't allowed in to see them and you
people in Care Homes where it ripped
through and killed a third of the people
in the home in two weeks and the
desperation that people felt at a cousin
lost his father who couldn't go and see
uh his dying wife and so on there were
disgusting there were terrible stories
criminal terrible stories it's
disgusting so let me ask you a question
as a professional because we're both
adults we're both very smart as a
professional which is more likely that
the government believed covid was deadly
and everybody should be truthfully
afraid and locked in their houses but
because they had this spirit inside of
them and they couldn't resist the idea
of a party decided to risk their lives
to party or they lied on the television
trying to scare everyone and enslave
them and lock them in their houses
knowing it's garbage knowing it's a lie
and not caring and had a party behind
everyone's back so they didn't think
they get caught which one is more likely
as a professional as a logical human why
don't we just agree that they were a
bunch of rank Hypocrites stupid people
who were behaving utterly selfishly to
the extent that the queen when her
husband Prince philli dies is in the
church on her own in a mass with none of
her family around her after losing a
rock of 70 years and it turned out the
night before down the street had had I
think two parties including a karaoke
party I think that was shameful and
disgraceful well I we can agree on that
we can agree on that and we can wake up
and start to realize oh maybe the
government doesn't care about us maybe
the government lies to us maybe they
tell us things and try and scare us but
they don't actually care themselves
maybe all they are is hypocritical
self-interested people maybe they are
maybe then and maybe they use the MSM to
purport their lives to keep everybody
enslaved well they do whatever they want
and that is the Matrix and and of itself
and if you speak against it and people
listen to you I'll repeat this your
ability to speak freely is directly
correl Rel to your insignificance if
you're as big as I was the most Googled
man on the planet telling the truth you
will pay the price Pierce and that is
why I was locked in that cell and I do
not regret it because I live true to God
I'm not going to sit here as a coward
and not tell the truth to people for as
long as I live until they put a bullet
in my head let me ask you about the
lover boy method so the suggestion is
that you and your brother and others uh
but you let's talk about you that you
deployed the lover boy method where you
would make women fall in love with you
you would then persuade them to do
webam webcam stuff right Tik Tok okay
but wait it's called it webcam stuff
right no it's not called it that the
indictment is about Tik Tok okay what
would you make the women do or what
would they do with you I don't make
anybody do anything in fact let's talk
about the lover boy method so it's very
interesting let's Imagine The Matrix is
pissed off with a set individual who's
telling too much truth and everybody is
listening to him and they decide they're
going to attack him with sexual assault
claims they say ah he's making women do
well we found conversations where he
gave advice on how to go viral on Tik
Tok he's making women do Tik Tok but he
isn't being horrible to them he's not
hitting them he's not being mean to them
so what can we do let's use the lover
boy method if I was abusive and mean
they wouldn't say lover boy method you
know lover boy method means being nice
he was nice and polite and kind and they
really liked him as a person and he told
them how to do Tik Tok a l boy of course
it is Andrew that's not what the lover
boy method is absolutely it is the lover
boy method is where perpetrators woo
victims with the prospect of a loving
relationship until they can be forced
into abusive situations or a form of
slavery this is garbage that's actually
it means the lover boy method is being
nice to people so that you work together
effectively what they're trying to say
here I was nice to girls who asked me
for Tik Tok advice and they sang It's
The Lover Boy method I didn't beat them
into doing Tik Tok I didn't force them I
didn't threaten them in fact I was like
yeah you're very pretty you can be
pretty famous element of coercion How
can there be an ele what does that even
mean let's be professionals here what
does that even mean what do you think
coercion means I was coerced into this
interview you came along to me and said
you weren't coerced into this inter yes
I was well don't tell me the bullying
MSM and said Andrew you've got to do an
interview and I'm going to fly all the
way toia to do it me that you used the
lover boy method you said sir the lover
boy meod yep Andrew this is going to be
a very interesting interview we had a
good one last time you're a nice guy we
have some interesting conversations I'm
going to come along minute wa a minute
we're going to make some money from this
interview money will be made for both
sides you L boyed me you stole the
profit minute just to be clear I've had
no conversation with you about this
interview and the conversations I've had
with your intermediary were very
professional and I said I would like to
do an interview were you nice of I'm
always nice lover boy you can't believe
you use niceness to lover boy me because
this is a profitable Enterprise and I
was cered here I make no pretense that
I'm into I've come all the way from
London to rainia to interview you
because yes I want to do it on my show
and that will clearly benefit me and my
show am I a full grown consenting adult
who decided to the idea but you're not
being coerced into do am I a full- grown
consenting adult who decided to do this
show yes okay so I wasn't coerced
correct what that got to do with what
I've asked you because you were nice to
me and you're saying that I wasn't nice
to you I didn't even talk to you being
nice is the lover boy method and that
adults have no responsibility and nice
to someone they they become your slave I
wasn't nice to you and I didn't call you
a nice guy I feel lover boy H I feel
lover boy I'm sorry well I'm sorry it's
fine it's you had a a website Hustler's
University offering courses teaching
husbands and boyfriends how to get their
Partners absolutely false the husters
university which you can go to now
actually change the domain it's
university.com is a school which teaches
modern wealth creation methods we teach
people how to make websites we teach
people Ecom why did you call it why did
you call it a PhD pimping hose degree no
you're talking about an old video which
was made satirically why did you call it
that oh that's Sati of course it was
nine years ago the internet was a very
different place and if you're going to
sit here and say oh nine years ago you
said stupid things on the Internet it's
not a gotcha moment because every single
person has so Of You' so of you cuz you
advocated for the vaccine sir so you
said stupid things on the internet like
that's how things go it's satirical I
also said I'm an astronaut do you
believe I've been to the Moon because I
haven't Believe It or Not hust
University teaches children how to make
websites and it teach and it's there
only one reason I'm ask only reason I'm
ask you you've repeatedly said in
interviews since you were arrested that
you have never categorize yourself as a
pimp you don't think you're a pimp right
well what about all the rappers did you
ask Ice Cube if he's a pimp and a
murderer and a drug dealer JZ sold crack
I'm not inter I'm not interviewing them
I'm asking you whether you have at any
stage in the last 15 years being a pimp
of course I've not been a pimp I've said
I'm a pimp I've said I'm an astronaut
I've said I'm a cowboy I've said I'm the
strongest man in the world I've said I'm
James Bond throw me in jail are you just
put me in jail I deserve it nine years
ago I made a joke on the internet so
here's my question are you are you a
fantasist I'm not a fantasist do you
have a Persona that's just not you of
course not I am me well if you are you
why would you repeatedly call yourself a
pimp and then now say you never been a
pimp are you going to sit here and say
that because I've once said oh I'm
curious ious whether if you you're
trying to say to me you didn't mean any
of the things you said so I'm asking
myself well why should I believe
anything you say now in other words is
what you say actually what you mean is
Andrew Tate real or do you have a
complete Persona that you fueled for
money that has nothing to do with the
real you I don't know you tell me I
exaggerated on the internet N9 years ago
for comedic effect I'd walk into a
nightclub and there'd be girls at my
table like every other man who walks
into a nightclub and I'd say Pimpin oh
no put me in jail 93 days was not enough
with the Cockroaches I should go back
this is a matrix attack Pierce every
single person every single man out there
has done things worse than I've done in
fact I will argue if you put 99.9% of
men through the level of scrutiny I've
been through by F by multiple federal
agencies you will find a lot worse than
him saying he was a pimp on the internet
nine years ago you will find actual
genuine crime and I've done nothing I
live true to God this is all garbage and
it's not real like I said to you I I
don't know if you're guilty or not I do
and I am not guilty Matrix attack I want
to be clear to you I'm not preempting
your guilt I've come here with a
completely open mind you've been charged
with serious offenses but I am not going
to judge you because I'm not a judge and
this is not courtroom right but it's
interesting to me that one of the
biggest charges against you is that
you're a misogynist and you've always
said I'm not a misogynist and the last
time I interviewed you you said well I
may have said some things that you know
may have been misconstrued but even in
the last week you've tweeted some stuff
which I'm not even sure if you're aware
as you tweet this stuff how it sounds
read it okay let's read this is quite a
long one sure but I think it's important
to read it to get a sense of how you
view women absolutely any woman I date
does not have a job um okay so the woman
you're with doesn't have a job no okay
do you date other women sometimes and
your partner's fine with that obviously
yeah and you you're fine with that why
wouldn't I be well you think it's fine
to be dating other women when you're
when you you have a mother I think we're
consenting adults and everybody can make
their own personal decisions fair enough
why would why I be working so hard you
say to have hundreds of millions of my
woman to waste her life enslaved pennies
no I will give you a life you can never
ever afford private jets festar hotels
new cars endless spending money and
diamonds you'll be rich because you're
praying for me every day and protecting
my spirit I work in the physical world
she works in the spirit realm would
women shouldn't have to work because
being a good partner is a full-time job
for a woman she has to look good all the
beauty treatments a Time intensive not
about money takes a lot of time you just
to train every day and stay in fantastic
shape Shops look amazing next to me I
know there are some men who do a hundred
times more than this on a daily basis
but women are not as organized as men
and achieving anything significant
causes them huge amounts of stress yeah
they need to have huge sections of their
day empty to waste or they will have a
mental breakdown true and do you want a
woman who's stressed and angry after the
commute unshaven and exhausted or do you
want a Barbie doll who's always smiling
and saying thank you because she did her
nails and brought you proud of that day
as a man unless you're a loser you're
already Filthy Rich right you can get
endless sex anyway Girls Are Easy so
what can a girl give you happiness Vibes
always smiling take the edge of a
stressful life can she always be happy
if she's been working all day no just to
wake up at 11:00 gym till 1 one
appointment and some shopping dress
Beautiful by 7:00 p.m. for you to finish
working and tell you how strong you are
no matter how pissed off you are just to
always be laughing and smiling and
writing your little notes about how
you're perfect and just to be playful
and funny she can't do that if she has a
job so your job is being my girlfriend
and now you're a milli iire
congratulations behave and aim for the
promotion to wife the reason I read all
that in detail was I don't think you
understand quite how that comes over
because I think that is the purest
definition of misogyny I probably ever
read well I don't think you understand
one especially when I'm talking about
the fact that women can't handle what
men can do Etc one it's slightly
sarcastic there's a sarcastic to do you
mean any of this I mean all of it any
woman I'm with I will provide for
because no woman should work they should
spend all day def find themselves for
you right and they might get promoted to
wife your job is being my girlfriend
there are there are hundreds of millions
of women around the world who do a good
day's work who still manage to be a very
good wife or partner agree completely
but it's my why would you encourage why
would you encourage a whole generation
of young men I mean I've got to be
honest since our last two interviews
before you arrested I would say every
single day I have young men teenage boys
Maybe early 20s coming up to me asking
about you it's gone on every day since I
interviewed you I'm very aware of your
reach I'm very aware of your influence
and I've I've whenever I've been asked
about you say what do you think of him I
said I don't really know I find myself
agreeing with 60 to 70% of the things
you say and I do because I think a lot
of the stuff you say about empowering
young men to be confident to work out to
take care of themselves to have enough
money to not all not force their woman
to work right that's the bit that's the
bit where when you stray into that kind
of language particularly in the detail
where you reveal what you're really
thinking a the kind of pathetic soulless
life you want for these women where does
it allow for being a mother for example
being absolutely that's how does a
mother of your children manage to find
time for being a mother how does in this
routine of love and Devotion to you does
how does having a job give her time to
be a mother this gives her all the time
in the world to be a mother one it
slightly sarcastic firstly what you mean
you tell by the tone do you mean you
don't mean it no I mean it which but
it's slightly sarcastic sarc comic
effect sarcasm means you don't mean it
no I mean it but it's slightly SAR you
mean it or you don't it's either
sarcastic or it's not I mean every
single word this is the conundrum with
you sarcastic this is the conundrum with
you right it's not a conundrum if you'd
let me explain it's not a conundrum at
all also very interesting I tweet this
out I get thousands of women begging me
inboxing me saying finally a man who
understands he needs to provide for a
woman so she can be her best self this
is exactly the kind of life that will
allow there are definitely women wom
that will absolutely love to be so why
don't you treated like misogynists uh no
but what I think they are they're people
who just basically it's the old sugar
daddy thing right they want to have a
rich guy who's going to pamper them and
take care of them they don't have to do
a day's work they just have to make
being a good partner is work well so you
say yeah but it also the language that
you use here seriously diminishes women
who do work you make them out to be well
you're not doing your job as a partner
or wife you should be doing your job
which is just to devote yourself to his
pleasure and making him well it's
actually interesting you say that
because I'll put a lot of the fault of
this on men let's let's if you want to
gender the argument let's do that I
think that a lot of the reason why women
can't live this life if they so choose
if you're a woman who decides to work
then go to work I don't care but if
you're a woman who decides she wants to
retire it's because she can't find a man
who could provide for her at this level
do you think when a woman marries a
billionaire that she wants to go get a
job in Starbucks cuz in my experience
when they marry extremely successful men
they don't want a job I'm sure Ronaldo's
wife isn't begging to go work in Ikea
actually's wife works very hard she
works for herself which is different and
her family of course yeah which is
different she's a hardworking woman
absolutely because being a fantastic
partner and having a bunch of children
is a bunch of hard work and she also
finds the energy to have us businesses
on the side fantastic what we're saying
here but you don't want women to have
businesses no I'm saying if you're with
a man of my stature you don't have to
work now if I met a perfect woman and we
were together and we were happy when you
say a man of your statute with respect
right now you have no income no
possessions correct facing you're facing
serious criminal charges I mean I'm not
quite sure what statue you think you're
currently selling but it ain't great
okay well then it's it's shame all those
women inboxed me after I put that tweet
out saying we agree with you I think you
should interview I met a woman yesterday
who when I said I was coming to
interview was immedi like or can you put
a good word in for me of course sure you
have a you have a definite appeal to a
certain type of woman there's no
question question providing for woman
financially is a man's responsibility if
that means I'm a misogynist then I'm a
misogynist I think so you accept you
accept you are a mass no I think a man
should provide for a woman financially
completely and utterly if she wants to
work if my partner were to say to me
right now I really feel like getting a
job it would make me happy then I'll say
work but she doesn't have to her job is
looking after the children looking after
me and being as happy as possible if you
think I'm a bad person for saying if you
actually read that read the subtext and
context okay good then you will
understand what I'm saying you know I
did you heard it absolutely so what I am
saying is I am a man my life is
stressful my life is pain I go to jail I
suffer I have to deal with making money
I have constant endless headache I do
all of that so I can give you everything
but then I get to have you your job is
to be happy I want you to smile I want
you to look your best and feel your best
all of the time if I'm I a misogynist
for saying that I go through so much
pain so that we can be financially
secure so I hope the woman I care about
does not have to work a job if that
makes me a bad person then so be it
because all I'm saying is I want to take
care of her in every single realm I take
care of her physical safety I take care
of her Financial Security that is is my
job as a man and if more men acted like
me you will see that the world would be
a happier and better place the women who
say I really want to work I want a
career that's their prerogative and
their decision they're allowed to do
that but also often the reason they do
that is because they can't find a man
they trust to take care of them I've had
this I've had this from women in their
own mouth if I found a man who was
financially secure and as smart as you I
wouldn't be doing this garbage job
either why was I scoped into working to
pay taxes when I should be at home
having children with a man door a Andrew
there are so many women that will listen
to that and be laughing and mocking you
will say don't be so ridiculous I have a
job that I love maybe they're being paid
even more than their man right the real
world isn't the one that you categorize
the real world is varied and nuanced but
I am talking about my life experience my
experience any woman I love does not
have to work unless she decides you're
the boss you're in charge her job is to
make you happy her job is to make
herself look good her job is to work out
for your benefit blah blah blah blah
blah it is actually just misogyny do you
think a woman looking do you think a
woman looking good and working out is
has no benefit at all to her of course
it does okay so it's not for my benefit
then is it see but when but when you
talk about when you talk about no no I
don't when you talk about young men and
you tell them to work out and take care
of themselves I cheer you on right I
want that I've got three sons I want
them to feel that don't you want them to
become very rich and successful and have
a woman who relies on them and have a
beautiful family no but I don't want a
woman who observ to them why is
subservience why is a woman literally
the tone of the tweet I read is
subservient you did another tweet this
week men Love by telling you what to do
and not allowing you to make stupid
decisions we save you from the female
inclination to make stupid choices if a
man isn't giv you instructions he
doesn't love you if you won't listen to
a man's instructions you don't love him
the whole language is so ridiculous let
me change the language then well you
tweeted this to 8 8.2 million people
correct so let me say this a father
loves
let's say instead of a man loves say a
father loves a father loves
disciplinarian that's how a father will
love you a mother will say oh I hope
you're happy hope you're doing okay but
but a father will come along and say no
don't do this you must do it that way
that's incorrect it has to be this way a
father will discipline you because a
father feels he knows best for you it's
the masculine essence of Love When a Man
Loves he shows that he cares by a degree
there is a massive difference between a
relationship between a father and a
child and between a man and a woman in a
relationship and I'm not sure you quite
get no there is a difference but I would
argue Pierce I would argue in the
happiest relationships it's a
traditionally masculine role in which
the man plays and provides the female is
traditionally feminine the man is the
head of the house not in abusive way
doesn't beat her up I'm talking about
the man being the head of the household
like I would like to believe you're the
head of your household and he comes
along and says what happens and what
doesn't happen because he's the man of
the house no that's not that's actually
not how most households operate well
then it sounds like we understand why
the entire world's a mess because only
10 years ago that's exactly how the
households operated there was a man of
the house and now we have no longer any
clear defined roles there's no more
longer a man of the house you want to
talk about knife crime kids doing drugs
the crime rate all of these problems we
talking about all of the societal ills
we Face perhaps it's because we don't
have any men in the house anymore
perhaps we need to bring the man of the
house back and the man of the house will
come along and be a disciplinarian and
he will make the set rules and the
Creeds of that house he will say within
in this household we don't take drugs
that stands for the woman I am with the
children who we have birthed nobody
takes drugs in this household because
this is my house and I'm the man of the
house so it sounds to me like we need to
bring it back sir yeah listen it's all
good Macho stuff okay and I know lots of
young boys who listen to this and go wow
that's how I should be then I read the
detail of your tweets and again come
back to this we save women from their
female inclination to make stupid
choices females are emotional if a man
isn't giving you instructions females
are emal hang
all this stuff is designed to exactly as
you've just articulated is designed to
make young men feel that the only way
they can be successful in life is to
effectively have their women under
control give them instructions buying
them they have to obey don't Don't Buy
Women you'll end up in jail you can buy
them Prada but let me let me finish my
point my point is that it seems to me
from reading your tweets even now that
you have a blind spot when it comes to
how they sound and it may and it may be
that the legal problems that you're in
which might be extremely serious and
we'll see when the trial happens but it
may be that in your head nothing you've
done is remotely inappropriate because
actually in your tweets you can see
there's an element there of wanting
coercion and control you want to control
women you want them to be effectively
your servants slaves for want of a
better place slav slaves who get Prada
and get to work out in the gym and get
to look good while I do but you
understand the point I'm making no I
don't because which is in your head the
line is blurred so much now with this
Macho rhetoric that you've actually lost
track of how this sounds here's all of
the things I even when I read that stuff
to you I could see you looking at me and
you you're answer is I was being
sarcastic and I said well where then you
go well no I meant it well you can't be
both I meant it and I said tone you
either mean it or it's well no because
sarcasm means you don't mean it Pierce
all the things you've just do you accept
that no I SM guy you know what sarcasm
means absolutely I said it has a
sarcastic tone for comedic effect all
the things I'm saying and the things
I've said are basically the way the
entire world fought only 10 years ago
you may buy into the scop you may buy
into the new thing I don't buy into any
scops uh we just talked about the
vaccine sir yeah the vaccines weren't
Sops of course not so I believe that
there should be a man of the house you
had a polio vaccine right correct why
because I didn't get polio I wouldn't
have a covid vaccine because I'd still
get covid plus probably myartis and have
a heart attack so
we believe there was a man of the house
years ago do you think statistically
more people got myocarditis by having
the vaccine or not having it I think
statistically we need to bring you don't
know do you why would I know why would I
look at the statistics studies that come
from The Matrix itself so the Matrix so
every fact you don't like because it
doesn't suit your agenda you just
dismisses Matrix no I'll give
you a very simple way I view the world
Co can't hurt me so why would I take
their
injection point
they tried to make us including you you
told people they should have the vaccine
if they don't have it they shouldn't
leave their house you know why because
at the time the scientists and by the
way scientist is ever evolving at the
time I said that the scientist said if
you had the vaccine it would prevent you
transmitting the virus matx that turned
out to be wrong and they issued updated
advice saying further studies said that
actually you could transmit it and at
that point you know what I did which you
never do I held my hands up I went I was
wrong because the advice changed and now
I would not say the same thing that is
called actually evolving opinions when
facts change that's actually how a
civilized democracy works oh is it we
live in a civilized democracy do we sir
I actually would argue that point with
you for very for a very long time I
don't think we live in a civilized
democracy another point I want to make
here if I had cancer or if I was a
threat of a genuine disease which could
actually harm me would the NHS text me
10 times a day trying to get me
treatment or would I be sitting there
waiting for month get an appointment
they wouldn't care about me they let me
die so the fact that they will endlessly
text me and try and beg me to get this
poison should been an alarm Bell for
anybody with a brain actually they I
tell you what the an sent me I'm a 58y
old man in the last few months they've
sent me uh one about a flu jab which I'm
going to have um because I think it
stops you getting flu and flu is nasty
uh a covid booster which I won't have I
think I've had enough of those I'm fine
with that thanks uh they sent me one
about having a check for a bow cancer
which I've done and came back negative
and so on and so on the NHS texting
system is for our benefit you don't have
to do it no one's holding a gun to your
head The Matrix isn't saying if you
don't have this Andrew Tate we're going
to we're going to do something to do you
have any idea not you've not being
treated in Romania by their system
because of anything to do with covid
vaccines and your attempt to try and
persuade people that that's the case is
ridiculous and you know it's ridiculous
do you have any idea how difficult it
was to remain unvaccinated peers let me
tell you from somebody who was
unvaccinated and traveled the world do
you have any idea how difficult that was
actually because countries had border
controls oh because they tried to force
everybody so to sit and say they weren't
trying to force you know what they did
they said come get the covid vaccine
it's good for you it's going to help
they tried to coarse you by being nice
they tried to lover boy everybody they
tried to use the lover boy method to
force people to get the covid vaccine it
just came to we need to put all these
people in jail they were being nice to
people trying to help them unbelievable
nobody forced you to have it did you
have the vaccine absolutely and utterly
not sir my principles are not for sale I
would have stayed in my house to the end
of human time and sat there as a pure
blood the last one the last pure blood
on the planet before I inject myself
with poison you're not making an MGM
trailer yes I am because it's a matter
of principle I am not a farm animal my
blood is mine it does not belong to the
government and I decide what is in it
right all right so you have a polio
vaccine but not one so your brilliant
brain is deter that you know more about
the medicinal and scientific benefits of
individual vaccines and the PO one you
decided with your brilliant brain will
have that but even though a lot of
people by the way have had side effects
to polio vaccines did you know that yes
correct is that the Matrix doing that no
I didn't say the Matrix gave him the
side effect I've just told you all the
reasons I didn't get the vaccine already
described it at length but you work out
with your brilliant mind which vaccines
to have correct okay correct you realize
you can join my email list on
corporate.com you can sign up for free
and I'll tell you which vaccine I
wouldn't come to you for vaccine advice
Andrew because you have zero experience
I didn't get didn't get the I did I
obviously did pretty good I avoided the
poison shot while everyone else got it
so I'm actually pretty proud with my
track record what happens if you're
found guilty of the things you're
charged with well then I'm going to have
to go to jail I assume what's the
maximum sentence you could get I don't
know I don't you do I I actually
genuinely don't you've never asked your
lawyers I it can be between three to
eight years I think so you do know I
don't know the maximum but if you were
to serve eight years having to serve
three months and know how bad that was
could you cope with that in a Romanian
jail interesting question could I cope
with it yes would I be the same
afterwards I'm not sure what do you
think even the three months did to you
as a
man
well it was a fantastic test from God to
make sure I am the man I say I am
because I think there's a lot of people
who speak about masculine Excellence who
are not the men they say they are when
trouble appears you often learn that
they are nothing but
postures I had nightmares for a very
long time I couldn't sleep I I struggled
with certain things I would check my bed
sheets every single night for
cockroaches religiously I had a problem
with that but I never turned to therapy
I never turned to drugs I understood
that all of these things are from God
and they're given to me so that I can
become a stronger version of myself and
I welcomed them all and I embraced them
all and now that I'm a better not
completely but almost better part of me
actually misses my nightmares Pierce
part of me misses training all night I
didn't sleep for weeks months you you
said you didn't have nightmares no I had
nightmares I said I didn't have
nightmares in jail when I left I did and
I kind of miss it because I had so much
time in the day to get things done and
now I'm sleeping a full six hours I feel
a little bit lazy so perhaps I need
another test from God and if God decides
Allah is the best of planners if he
decides I need eight years in jail then
I will Embrace those eight years in jail
and do my absolute best to come out as
the most formidable version of myself
have you felt suicidal at all in the
last year I don't believe in suicide is
Haram I know you've said that before but
did you feel like you may want to end it
all I would never kill myself under any
circumstances so the day they put that
on the news when they finally take me
out you can know it's a lie it's Haram I
would never kill myself lock me in that
cell for the rest of my life I would
never kill
myself while you under house arrest you
you tweeted this avoid women who go to
festivals they're either on some losers
table who's feeding them cocaine or in a
crowd of sweaty peasants because they're
a sweaty peasant endless Instagram
stories screaming and having fun to
prove to the world they're worthless
hard past festy H correct I tweeted that
yes again why would you categorize all
women who go to festivals in such an
unpleasant way I actually categorized
all men who went to festivals also did
you read that tweet why are you
gendering the argument I think all
people who go to festivals are stupid it
is peasantry I've never been to a
festival in my life I'm not going to
stand there and scream and jump up and
down for some other human like he's God
I think the whole thing is embarrassing
all of it from head to toe it's all
sweaty peasantry and it's all just drug
fueled Insanity so why are you gendering
the argument when I insult the women who
go to festivals and also the men who go
to festivals because all of it is
peasantry head to toe and I do not
regret it all Festival or peasantry
anybody who goes I do not associate with
I've never been to one in my life I
never will so you've never been to one
how do you know what they're like I can
see enough I've seen the sweaty bodies
bumping into each other high on ketaman
pretending that the song they heard on
the radio at home is now more fantastic
because they're listening to it from a
loudspeaker embarrassing to be clear
you'd never been to one correct okay my
infinite brain that understands vacc
perfectly we have established your brain
is unique correct uh you you tweeted a
picture of Amanda Holden very good
friend of mine uh it's a very harmless
picture she's in a bikini on holiday
under a rain shower uh looking
extraordinarily uh beautiful in a sexual
pose and you tweeted you are a wife and
a mother and you're far past a teenager
there's no need for this post agreed
again it's just misogynist to say that
it's not misogynist kind a woman of her
race she's just turned 50 why can't a
woman of that age actually show off her
beautiful body in a in a nice bikini
like that what's wrong with that you can
call me crazy you can call me
misogynistic but I think once you reach
the ripe age of 50 any woman should not
be interested in thirst trapping on
Instagram I think she has bigger
responsibilities I'm sure she's a very
intelligent lady and she's done amazing
things she's famous she's obviously very
capable and I think she could do things
more interesting than standing around
trying to thirst trap on Instagram like
she's 18 I think she's above it I wasn't
insulting her I was reminding her that
she's actually such a fantastic person
she's done such amazing things in her
life and she's so achieved that she's
actually above thirst trapping I was
reminding of her of her worth because as
a feminist we're all feminists here
right we all believe in women
empowerment I'm reminding of her her of
her worth are you a feminist sure you're
not though are you I believe in feminine
empowerment and I think feminine
empowerment is in yes I do and feminine
empowerment is in modesty modesty is
empowering for Fe for females believe
taking your clothes off from Men on
Instagram is not empowering it's
empowering when you say no man but my
husband can see my body that is female
empowerment and I was reminding her of
that I was reminding her of her ripe age
and her intellect and there is no need
for that how old are you now I am 36 36
years old at what point will your antics
you know chugging your cigars in your
ripped body in your compound with your
security and your Bugattis at what age
does that become a thirst trap I don't
know if that ever stops being a thirst
trap because so it's fine for you once
again one rule for the man another rule
for the woman it's interesting because
I've never heard this argument before
but I'm extremely intelligent I've
already deciphered how this is going to
go from head to toe it's called I guess
we can look at peacocks right the male
peacock he shows look who I am looks
look what I can do look at my
achievement look at my beautiful
feathers and I guess you could call it
peacocking to a degree I'm showing the
world I'm extrem I'm extremely physical
cap I'm extremely physically capable yes
that's correct I'm extremely financially
successful you stripping off for
Instagram is fine it's not stripping off
for Instagram I'm boxing when you box
you Bo no top on you do it all the time
with your cigar and you're showing off
your Rip but that's fine for you but if
a man to Holden dares do it that is
apparently thirst trapping I think me
boxing with no shirt on is different
than a 50-year-old woman post you just
box I've seen you doing ones where you
wander around all Moody with your cigar
and your topless and stuff so fine for
you are you a fan Pierce uh no I just
think it's first trap do you yeah well I
don't do that perhaps it's successful
maybe you should start perhaps it's
successful because I do have a lot of
female fans out there in the world and
they pretend I'm a misogynist but it
turns out that 85% of women on the
planet seem to agree with me every
single woman I've ever met in real life
agrees with me I have no female hate at
all I've never had NE negative
interaction with women ever yes you have
with who what about the BBC journalist
it came to your
compound
Lucy yes oh I've never had a negative
interaction with a female I don't think
she was a fan I think she was how would
categorize that as a negative
interaction well she seemed to follow me
around for a long time I think she was a
little bit there lots of women Andrew
there are lots of women I know
personally there are lots of women who
find you incredibly offensive I don't
think so right it's their right to it's
your right it's your right to not care
but the idea that somehow you're this
beloved person for the world's females I
think is uh not true you are for a
certain type of woman who likes to be
treated in the way that you like to
treat women well let's counter that
argument right because the world as I
said at the beginning is nuanced am I
beloved by all females no but when I'm
sat here with someone as prestiged as
you who says you're a misogynist and you
hate women and women hate you I think
you talk in a way that is misogynistic
yeah okay well then you make it sound
like all women hate me and that's also
not the case of course it's a Nuance say
old women hate some some women agree
with me some women don't agree with me
when I said that post about aand Holden
a lot of women said Andrew that's
actually completely correct she's
extremely famous and there's no need for
her to be posting video pictures like
this at her ripe age I was actually
empowering her I believe that female
empowerment is in modesty but you don't
actually believe in feminism I believe
in the idea of you believe in
masculinity controlling women no they
have to take instructions from you they
have to do what you tell them and that
is actually what love and relationships
are about no I believe that men and
women have different roles I believe
that we were created differently by God
because we are the perfect team I
believe that a man who's in his
masculine frame is best suited by a
woman who's in her feminine frame I
believe when we work together we can
achieve amazing things whether it's
raising children or preserving society
and I believe a man has certain jobs and
a woman has certain jobs you don't
understand this about the things I say
when I said there that women make bad
decisions in the Tweet you referenced
earlier the point I was making is that
women are more emotional than men that
is their superpower that is fantastic
that is a great thing I love female
emotionality in the Tweet before you
tried to use against me I was talking
about how I love woman to be happy all
the time smiling all the time while I'm
stressed I love female emotionality the
reason women are bettered with children
the reason women are bettered with
children is because they're emotional is
their
superpower in a position you're not even
remembering what you wrote of course it
is I said female women are more
emotional than men is exactly what I
said I'm saying that is a fantastic
thing but there is no light without dark
so in certain situations the
emotionality is positive in certain
situations the emotionality is negative
we can also argue the same for men
because what happens to me is everyone
tries to gender my arguments we can
actually argue the same with men
stoicism male stoicism is positive in
certain scenarios it can be negative in
others we can come across as
unempathetic or not care because we're
stoic certain situations it benefits I
know people who've told me that their
kids who in their late teens they're at
schools where the name Andrew Tate is
banned nobody's allowed to mention your
name because the teachers think that
your brand of masculinity is so toxic
they are seeing a immediate effect on
the way young men behave and not in a
good way is that what the teachers think
is it yeah well I am actually genuinely
concerned by the fact that I've been
banned from schools when I do nothing
but preach masculine strength and
Excellence but then if you actually
understand how the society is going and
how the world works and all the insanity
they're trying to push on all of us I
can understand why they banned me
because I speak the truth if I was
wearing a wig Pierce and lipstick and
telling young boys to remove their
genitals would I have been banned from
schools no they would have say no you
can say his name no problem no matter
how big I got if I had a wig on and
lipstick and I had been castrated
medically I would be allowed to talk to
the young boys but as soon as I say
You're supposed to grow up and get big
and strong and if your wife doesn't want
a job you need to pay for her it's your
job as a man you better find some money
then I'm the Public Enemy Number One
garbage on that last point you don't say
if a woman doesn't want to work and man
to take care of it you say a woman
shouldn't work I said my woman won't
work right I'm talking about my personal
experience I said any girlfriend of mine
because I'm an extremely fortunate
financial position I was before Romania
took everything of course I have
hundreds of millions of dollars so
because I am in my position I would not
want my woman to work I think there's
more important things she can do if you
have hundreds of millions of dollars
where you said you had a worth of 17
million no I said they took 17 million
years where's the rest uh they must have
taken it I think they have it or maybe I
lost it I think I lost it somewhere you
you've never had hundreds of millions of
dollars of course not we haven't have of
course not you said they took all your
assets exactly well did they or didn't
they of course they took everything I
mean they'll be watch watching this are
they to assume that there are hundreds
of millions more dollars they haven't
got yet watching that's right they
absolutely everything you have it all
right but again is that all just a smok
and mirrors is that all just the the top
G stuff that you play up to which is has
no bearing on reality I was the most
Googled man on the planet I was the most
relevant man amongst 18 to 35y old males
which are the highest earning and
spending people on the planet do you
really think that I am not I can't pay
my bills Pierce right now yeah okay some
paying them for you correct you're right
someone's paying them for me you're
right my girl's got a job she works at
Starbucks exclusive Andrew tapes girl
top G's girl works in Starbucks to pay
the rent I've been
exposed see again I don't know what to
believe when you say stuff like that
well I'm telling you my friend that the
remaining States I think you deployed
deliberate smoke in mirrors because you
think it plays up to the brand Romanian
State have taken all of my money and I'm
just you know getting by MH that's
what's happened
do you worry about your impact on young
men I think that I like I said I'll be
completely honest I think a lot of what
you say they should be hearing Y and I
have tangible proof every day when I
walk around that they are listening to
everything you say but there is other
stuff you say where I don't want my sons
especially in that impressionable late
teenage to be listening to that correct
and that's a I don't want my daughter to
grow up and think that actually her only
success in life will come if she's at
home as some kind of servant to her man
well that won't be her only success but
that's an actual that's a very
professional question and I'll give a
very professional answer I have a
massive responsibility with great power
comes great responsibility and I
understand that young men do listen to
everything I say I do think I say good
things but you also made a very
pertinent point there you talked about
the impressionable age of a teenager and
it's very easy for a teenager with their
hormones and their lack of life
experience to take the things I say and
weaponize them and use them in the
incorrect context however that is not my
fault you could argue that 16 17 year
olds could look at anything on the
internet and misunderstand it you could
argue that all of this transgender
garbage and all these rappers talking
about killing each other and all these
drill artist talking about stabbing
their enemies could be misunderstood by
a 16-year-old so that's not my fault
however on that I totally agree so I
have a massive responsibility and you
are held to a different account actually
to a lot of those rappers absolutely
right there's no question I mean the far
of me was when John Legend rewrote the
lyrics to Baby It's Cold Outside because
apparently encouraged sexual assault but
wouldn't say a negative word about any
of the disgustingly misogynist and and
actually very violent lyrics of his rap
friends that to me is total hypocrisy
and it is HP hypocritical however unlike
all of these other people I have taken
into account my massive power and my
massive responsibility and I try to make
sure that I use my words as carefully as
possible so that they cannot be
misconstrued or misunderstood can I make
sure that no teenager on the planet who
listens to me ever misunderstands me
ever no I can't do that but I am doing
my very best what do I actually talk
about what do I actually say I what I do
is I come come along and let me give you
the broad overview of my message you're
a man so your life sucks it's always
going to suck and it's going to be pain
you're going to do nothing but suffer
you're going to suffer as a nobody or
going to suffer the pain it takes to
become actually most men don't have that
but that you're going to suffer as a
nobody because trust me nobody suffer or
you're going to suffer the pain it takes
to become great life is not supposed to
be a happy picnic you're supposed to get
up work hard dedicate yourself get
strong get rich go through whatever it
takes to become somebody of significance
That's My overall message and I believe
it's a positive you got to get rich to
be happy no in fact most of the super
rich people I know in life are
incredibly unhappy really so you're
setting a kind of full Dream well I
don't a lot of rich people are miserable
have you ever seen a rich person give
Mone lot of people who have very little
money can be very happy have you ever
seen a rich person give their money away
yes of course okay do you give all your
money away will I make you happier
Pierce I don't know do you want the
Romanian state to take it all I didn't
smile that day and let me tell you that
the reason I tell about men to become
financially successful is for two
reasons one because you have a job as a
man to protect and provide you can do
neither of those things if you are broke
that's the first reason and the second
reason I actually preach to young men to
become as financially successful as
possible is a greater broader reason and
I believe we've entered a very
interesting stage in humanity where the
Matrix has finally cracked three or four
years ago there were certain narratives
you could not talk against but with Elon
Musk owning X and now we have Rumble we
have a lot more information on the
internet people are starting to tell the
truth about many different subjects
there's a whole bunch of them we can
name and I like the idea of people who
are free thinking with a free mind we're
not Matrix control making as much money
as possible because it takes money to
win Wars and I want these people to be
financially successful that's why I tell
all of my fans who believe in me to
become as rich as possible because they
understand that everything the
government does is lie to them we need
Finance you use the word truth there I
don't think it's necessarily that people
want to promote truth they want to
promote their opinions often people's
opinions on facts can be very different
people can take the same set of facts
and different opinions doesn't mean it's
the truth right well that's true but I
don't believe in this my truth crap
right neither do I there are facts which
have to be accepted then you can have
opinion about them you and I can
disagree about all sorts of opinions but
actually not facts okay but I can argue
this point where the Matrix comes out
with a fact and all the opinions
countering that fact are censored and
they are destroyed then that fact
becomes de facto truth because it's the
only version of reality which exists to
be ingested by the mind so you still
need varing opinions on all public do
you think that what you uh let's let's
put it this way sure you would have
relationships with women and encourage
to take part in webcam sexual stuff no
well actually yes why are we going back
to this because there's one question I
want to ask you about it right and both
sides made a lot of money sure right
okay and in most cases because they
haven't complained in most cases you
would assume it was a mutually
beneficial transactional relationship
right I can assume that because
thousands of women have been through
this and most of them haven't come
forward and complained about the way
they were treated there was
transactional but was it moral do you
think what you've been making money from
Park the illegality aspect to one side
do you feel it was moral 10 years ago I
helped women promote their profiles on
the internet correct 10 years ago
firstly I have not been involved with it
for seven years it's not how I make
money I haven't touched it for a very
long time seven years is a long time you
made a lot of money from it I made some
money from it a long time ago how much
some money I can't even remember
millions millions perhaps Millions so
you made millions of pounds a long time
ago well hang on it's important you made
millions of pounds from sexual webcam
activity where you and the woman doing
the webcams would make money you accept
that no what I did is there is how you
made money no a long time ago and I
talked about this at length on many
different podcasts I don't hide it I
said a long time ago 10 years ago I
helped women with the tax side and the
technical side and the promotion ofes
the promotion of their profiles on
certain websites and I said about this
and I said I haven't been involved with
it for seven years the only reason this
is even coming up again is because I'm
monumentally famous because nobody cares
we're in B Pier we're in Bucharest
Romania do you understand that there is
a video chat studio with girls talking
to men online right there outside that
window in fact there's about 10 or
15,000 women in this city who do that
job now and the fact that I had some I
dipped my toe in it 10 years ago isn't
even significant I'm only asking if you
think it's moral do I think it's moral
because you speak in such a morally
self-righteous way now do you think that
that was moral well I wasn't religious
back then but let me sit and because
you're now you you converted to Islam
correct you're a Muslim they have you
know a code of behavior do you think
that that fell short of I have to answer
as a professional and as a professional
I would say judging by my current code
no I do not think that women being naked
on the Internet is moral however there
is like so you made money immorally you
can admit that it's nuanced like all
things peers at the time I was atheistic
I know that some of my girls talked men
away from suicide a lot of men are
ridiculously lonely I would also say a
lot of the lessons I know about men and
how they think and how lonely and sad
they can be and how difficult life is as
a man actually came from that era
because I saw a lot of very successful
men with a wife and with kids and with
money pouring their heart out to some
20-year-old they never met about how sad
they were I learned a lot about the
world and I know that a lot of suicide
was prevented and I made a lot of women
millionaires but would I do it now no
however I'm in a very different
situation now I'm a different person I'm
religious I'm also extremely financially
successful please understand Piers I
come from Marsh Farm Luton I came from
one of the worst areas inside of the UK
I could have stabbed someone every all
of my friends are breaking into cars
breaking into houses most of my friends
are in jail what did I do I promoted
accounts on the internet didn't didn't
sell crack didn't sell drugs didn't rob
anyone didn't shoot anyone and now
because I am successful I'm going to be
held to this moral standard by people
who grew up in fancy homes with white
picket fences and went to private school
I am from Marsh Lon and the biggest
crime I committed was completely legally
promoting internet profiles there are
people around me who did follow for far
less no no you're only going to be held
to the standard of the religion you've
converted to which you've already when
you take the shahada all your former
fins are already said would look at that
as immoral when you take the shahada all
of your former sins are erased and I
actually encourage you to find the light
and convert to Islam how you take thank
you very much thank you
sir